Speaker 1: The Troubles continue to mount for
MyPillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell, known to
us as Mike Pillow. His bank is now saying no more
pillow. Mike Lindell says a bank is closing his
accounts over fear of reputational damage.
Money problems continue to plague MyPillow
CEO turned election conspiracy theorist Mike
Lindell writes Salon with the staunch Trump ally,
revealing Friday on Bannon's podcast. He has
been asked by his bank, Heartland Financial,
to close his accounts over fear of the
institution's reputational damage if they
continue to be associated with pillow pillows says
they gave him 30 days to take business elsewhere.
The alleged representative said the institution
is afraid his bank records might be subpoenaed by
federal authorities, presenting a risk to the
bank's image. But the request apparently fell
on deaf ears, Pillow told Bannon. He refuses to
pull his money. I said, quote, I so quote. I said
quote, I am not being part of this. I'm
not leaving. You're going to have to
throw me out of your bank. And Lindell
quote and end the quote that he was quoting.
OK. This is all again. It's the same. This is
all standard. Banks do this. It's a part of risk
mitigation. They do customer due diligence. They
look at so-called politically exposed persons.
This all falls under the kind of Bank Secrecy Act
anti-money laundering risks that banks evaluate.
One of the risks that banks face is reputational
risk. If a bank feels that an existing client or
a potential client might be a threat to the bank's
reputation, they can choose to close the accounts.
Conservative subreddits are losing their
minds. They think this should be illegal.
They're also against business regulation.
But they want to mandate that a bank give
pillow an account. I mean, that doesn't make
any sense. And I thought that businesses were
allowed to choose their customers when it's a gay
wedding cake that a baker doesn't want to bake.
But I guess in this case, they don't.
Don't banks have a right to decide
who they will bank for? Do these right wingers
believe that having a bank account at a specific
bank is a right because it's not? You literally
have to apply to open one and you could be
accepted or you could be declined. I was once
declined for a bank account, a business bank
account. I don't remember why it was frustrating.
It was something about the nature of our business.
It might be that just having anything that's
on error has some risk with it legal risk, but
it's like nobody was taking away. Certainly not a
speech, right? And the bank was not violating any
law. They weren't saying, David, because you're
Jewish. We're not opening a bank. They're saying
because of the nature of your business. We don't
want a bank you. And it shouldn't really shock
us because some of these people seem to
think having a Twitter account is a right.
It's not, by the way, and management reserves
the right to refuse service to anyone
applies in this situation. As long as it's
not for your membership in a protected class,
they can't say we're kicking pillow out because
these are supposed Christian or because he's white
or because he was born in the U.S., or because
he's a man or because he's heterosexual,
that would be against the law. But the
reality is, no legitimate business should
want anything to do with Mike Pillow, and he is
now going to have to go find a new bank account.